yes
man where's isabella
look she's out of here
shoes where'd she go
recording in progress canada
so good to see you
hi good to see you too
jason i mean you you're like an honorary
canadian we miss you up here i know man
you mean a key to the city of toronto
i'll talk to the mayor man come back
i don't know you must have loved living
here right i did but i've shot so many
things in canada i've never worked more
in canada than anywhere else in the
world so i definitely should get some
residency at some point
you're an honorary today congratulations
to both of you in this film cue the
tears it was dramatic and isabella to
see you in this role was just
i don't know even how to respond but i
just want to say it is absolutely
amazing i applaud you and you know jason
you're a producer to be able to see
isabella bring rachel cooper to life
must been such a moment for you
especially while you're playing an
emotional role as her dad what i mean
what was it like for you um it's just a
massive
um
it's just like being my daughter you
know i mean it's just extremely
extremely proud i mean the first time
she came in
i'm not looking at her just as an actor
i'm you know because i am producing
because my best friend's directing is a
lot on the line it's her first time
doing something so i'm really really
watching her and
and
trying to be there and make sure she has
everything she needs but
she killed it you know she started the
show
it was beautiful just to watch her
um you know she already had a successful
career i think um
you know i'm excited for the world to
see it because
i think my career kind of came up the
same way and a lot of people knew about
me for many years and then all of a
sudden like bam oh they're there this
girl's just a
beast
she's a little oompa loompa beast
she's so powerful she's so powerful and
then to do those fight things like that
that is not it's not easy and she did
them all
you know i use my stunt double most of
the time she did
barely she really
yeah i do i do i do i support my i
support my stunts and i support them you
know i want the best for them but i it's
i need their help there's just stuff
that i can't do
and let's talk about that as well you
were kick-ass you're like this vigil
vigilante hero angry every little moment
that you had this is very different from
many roles that you've taken on i mean
what did it feel like for you to go to a
darker place and take this role on
um
fun it felt really fun i don't i don't
like to do the same thing over and over
again i would get very bored playing the
same kind of character so you know when
i read the script it was enticing it was
talking about issues that i studied for
two years in psychology
um so you know i i would love to dive
into the the whole psychological
um side of this movie and the sequel
perhaps
yeah sequel look at that
and you worked with aquaman does this
mean you want to go into the world the
superhero and if you could which one
would you want to be
i don't know i feel like i want to do
something that's really gritty and dark
but also funny like a deadpool type
thing
oh yes ryan reynolds yes i mean that
would be a lot of fun yeah i don't know
if it's in deadpool i don't know we're
just we're just thinking of fun ideas
here
and you know what's so great is that
there's so many great quotes in this
jason there was one that said we're
nothing more than the experience that
made us and i thought that was really
powerful especially with you guys taking
on these roles
and it got me a little bit curious about
what are some moments in your life or a
moment that was a pivotal moment that
changed you
uh
when i got my dog
okay that's a good one jason
uh pivotal moment in my life i mean
you know i think the moment that i had
became a father was definitely um
it all kind of happened at the same
moment where
i fell in love
and tell my wife
made babies and then you know it all
kind of shifted too
i had a very uh
um not very successful career
i've done a lot of tv shows on a lot of
different kinds of things but
um i really
dug deep and that's when i started
directing that's why i met brian
and i uh just very motivated to i wasn't
gonna wait by the phone anymore and i
was tired of people thinking i was just
one way so i just went out and did it on
my own and i made proud of your season
that's the reason why we're here today
is brian's now
he's been my dp for years and we made
all our stuff and
it's really because um i couldn't get
these kind of roles i couldn't get the
opportunity so i went out and made them
so that's kind of the moment where you
just go family
kids will motivate you
yeah yeah yeah they really do and the
dog and the dog too congratulations
you